so you said you're a massive board game
fan and i've seen some of your videos
like reviewing board games and
everything as well dismay of your
youtube yeah to just see this to the
dismay of like your entire audience it
seems like i will say though on that
like even though i make fun of the fact
that they don't get a lot of views uh
there was one time i think i did
so
those of you don't know i uh in
tumblr days i did goofy covers right
yeah yeah yeah and then uh uh everyone
that used to be the thing i was like
dude on the goofy do another cookie
cutter and i was like if i become known
as the goofy cover man
i'm going to walk into the ocean
i cannot let this be my legacy
so i stopped
and then
that was maybe like i don't know eight
maybe like eight years pass or whatever
yeah and then for a charity milestone i
was like okay i will do a goofy cover
and then i was like oh this is kind of
fun again so i started doing it yeah but
then like i posted one and then someone
was like what the hell is this [ __ ]
where are the board game reviews i'm
like
nothing
nothing i can do is will please anybody
like but but i was like wow the board
game reviews have been around for so
long that even then people are like
we want that like they hate change they
hate any kind of like this isn't what
you do you do the skits eating 20 things
and these shitty board game reviews that
don't do well
not this what is this thing i'm like
okay
um
but yeah anyway just can't get a dub man
yeah
uh
what's that you were asking yeah what
are some board games you recommend
because like i'm not so much into the
board game scene and so like i see
someone like you and i you know
occasionally watch some of your reviews
and some of your videos what like what
to you makes a good board game what do
you what have you played if anything
[ __ ] the
monopoly i've made them play uh ticket
to ride
tickets
that's that's fun i really like risk as
well yeah okay yeah um
if you
um let's see
like uh do you like cooperative games do
you like uh
more competitive games like what are you
what are you what's your style
i'd say
let's say cooperative cooperative yeah
yeah yeah like pandemic is like a good
one to start uh that one's you're
running around the world trying to like
you know cure disease yeah
and nowadays
yeah
and feel sad about how the real one's
going away yeah
like that's that one's good um
maybe we should have played that before
like yeah
right now that's a lot we're in a
[ __ ] long campaign right now right
my favorite board game is marvel
legendary which is a cooperative uh deck
building game right deck building being
like not like magic uh where you build
it
it's like you have a market of cards
you're playing like slay the spire or
something any of you i've never played
slaves okay anyway wait i i know
obviously this fire i know how it works
deck building as a concept is like you
have these random cards you add you
slowly start adding them to your basic
deck and then like get rid of all your
shitty cards and your deck becomes
stronger as you go right right
inscription yes inscription is a deck
building game yeah the description was
really really good yeah it was an
amazing game um so like a lot of the
deck building ones are really good
i mean i don't know it really just
depends on
what you
what you've got so many
reviews you've done yeah it's just like
oh my god yeah i saw like the table that
you got given
i'm obsessed with this table guys yeah
it looks so [ __ ] cool this table he
got he's like the best [ __ ] thing
ever i mean you want to come see it yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah it's it's like i would like to get
that table just to play board games you
know i'll get that table first and i'm
just like okay now i need to get now i
need some board games to play is it bad
that i think i'm remember the name is it
the woodworm table or something the uh
the wormwood oh my gosh is the company
okay all right right it's this table
that just like there's a like a it's a
normal table and then it just all comes
off with magnets there's cupholders that
can slide around yeah it's just a
playing area with like a felt it looks
amazing yeah
it's beautiful
like i was using my kitchen table for a
long time with like a with a mat right
um and that was fine but then like this
thing i'm like oh it's so it's so good
like
the table topper uh before this uh
whenever we ordered food or whatever and
the games on the table it's like all
right everyone go stand awkwardly in the
kitchen and like eat off my counters or
whatever yeah yeah but now it's like
okay break put the toppers on we can eat
on top
it's so good cup holders it's just
beautiful it's awesome dude this thing
is awesome yeah yeah i want that's like
the premium board game experience that i
won
how did you get like how did that hobby
start was that something you were always
like into and then you just kind of like
grew from there it started from um uh i
was at an otakon back in like i want to
say like 2012 or something like right
it's not even maybe around then is
odocon
that's in uh it used to be in baltimore
now in dc okay uh and uh just a group of
friends and i we were at there was
there's a barnes noble in the inner
harbor where that khan used to be and uh
none of us had really played a lot of
designer board games or whatever we saw
a game called forbidden island uh which
is a great game actually right and the
cover was cool they had a silly name
we're like oh what is this like let's
just buy it like if it's stupid it we'll
just you know it's fun let's just try it
yeah and if it's great and we were
really into it it's a cooperative game
where like you're trying to collect
these artifacts and the island is
sinking and you have to get off like in
time or whatever yeah um simple design
but very fun and we were like oh [ __ ]
this is great like are there other games
like this and so it became like a rabbit
hole we would it's yeah like i i i often
introduce a lot of people to
the hobby right like oh have you tried
this and then they're like oh [ __ ] like
board games can be like this because a
lot of people are associated with like
monopoly
yeah yeah um or even like you know for
me katan i find kind of dull like i had
played katan prior and i was like this
is fine i don't really give a [ __ ] but
forbidden island i was like oh okay
these can be like and now i play like
everything yeah um
because then you discover like there's a
website called board game geek that like
you know ranks all the games
and it becomes and then people started
gifting me
games yeah yeah yeah um so it really
just snowballed right so the complexity
of those board games is just insane yeah
the learning curve right there like
multi-day things right like they could
be well
i think multi-day might be an
exaggeration but there's definitely ones
that i've played that taken like maybe
like 12 hours
like that's like
all right comment like in the morning
and you we will be done at like 11 p.m
like
that's a commitment man yeah yeah that's
and for me actually the
sweet spot is like middle complexity
yeah light to middle yeah because i like
complex games but they're harder to get
to the table because only like
die hards are going to want to like play
those it's hard to teach it to people
it's hard to teach people it's
intimidating and oftentimes very hard to
you know just get into so they're sort
of like on board game they sort of from
like one to five scale right like the
two to three scale is usually like
perfect because it's like one or two is
like party games which are fun but two
to three is like there's some meat on
these bones but it's not like it's not
that hard to grasp yeah once you get to
three to four that's a little beefier
four and up is like that is complex like
it is you have like a good like gate
like you want to get someone into board
games you have like a good gateway game
you're like that you always bring out to
be like monopoly
here's his little thing to like wait
your appetite just to see like what this
hobby what about not only beyond that
difficulty what is it
i think it's probably i could even
search right now my guess is like one or
something right
like maybe with the trading it's
slightly but it's you're literally just
rolling dyson yeah yeah yeah exactly
um let's see a good
gateway
game like what's the attack on titan of
board games you know
i mean
ticket to right yeah i feel like ticket
to ride is a really good interest that's
a good one just because it's so simple
and like yeah you're just making sets
and like making
i know i don't care if this is not
protocol on your own problem you can
yeah yeah you can you can do it because
i i like to get to riots i find that
there is a way
for me it's like if you can have the
opportunity to strategize
and really like implement it while still
having that that luck factor yeah where
a noob could just completely get lucky
and beat you like i like that that's
what i really like about risk yeah it's
exactly the same thing where it's like
it looks
really intimidating because it's such a
big game but yeah when you actually get
into and you learn the rules it's very
you can very quickly start strategizing
right now so some good ones like azul is
a very uh elegant like sort of abstract
game with like really nice tiles
and that one has like like there's
different ones in the series that's
there's like a zoolo
stained glass of cintra and it's just
like
it has the feel of like a game that's
been around for like you know decades
but it's it's a new what you do in that
game um it's hard to explain without
visuals but you're basically you have
these circles of tiles and you're
drafting colors of tiles and you're sort
of filling up rows okay you're trying to
get them in like an array make combos
right which is completely impossible to
explain without me actually having the
pieces yeah
but it has the females
do your best
so there's there's that one um
like a really popular one it's like code
names have you ever played that one do
you know that one
codenames is like you have a grid of
words uh and one person or your your
each team has a code map code name or
code master or whatever right and they
give a clue like uh
furry three and their your team is
trying to like pick what are the which
of these were three words fit that clue
but the thing is if you touch a clue of
the other team's words they get the
point right and there's a kill word
where if anyone touches that they
instantly lose oh so it's like it's like
an array of like i think like 25 words
half of them are red on the back half of
them are blue yeah not on the back
there's like a little card and then they
have them are blanks which are like duds
and then there's a kill card right
there's like a really like elegant just
like hey this is this i i basically just
explained how to play it now yeah yeah
yeah
and a number and that's how many fit
that thing and just and you're like okay
it's a good party game it's a really
good party game yeah
uh
i'm gonna write these down yeah yeah
yeah luckily it's being filmed right now
right yeah
uh dixit you know dixon oh i love dixit
it's just very very it's a really fun
game that is one where you're playing um
these surreal picture cards uh and
you're trying to give a clue as to uh
like it's like reverse pictionary almost
the idea is that you wanna um
get uh give a clue
so that not
everyone uh picks the card uh because if
everyone picks the card then
you get [ __ ] but if nobody picks your
card you get [ __ ] so you're trying to
give a clue that's just
obscure enough where it's like because
what happens is you put down the card
and everyone else puts down a card that
matches that clue right right everyone's
trying to and you're trying to you're
trying to figure out which one was the
original card right so if i said like uh
uh mysterious or whatever and i put down
a card and everyone else puts down a
card then we reveal them and everyone's
like which one was the original
mysterious card right one that's fun in
that game as a clue super mario brothers
three
because then everything because then
there's so many surprisingly like
fitting cards right right
or like something like that or you say a
video gamer or like dreamworks movies or
something and then like people are
revealing they all look like [ __ ]
dreamworks movies yeah all the cars look
like salvador dali paintings they're
like really abstract they're all really
strange like surreal okay
yeah that one's really fun that one's
really good um from an island i
mentioned it's a really fun co-op yeah
um yeah those are like just some some
very like basic level ones so that
sounds really fun yeah thank you for the
recording yeah thank you for the
recommendations yeah future trash taste
talking yeah hell yeah i'm down you're
just giving us content ideas now that's
perfect yeah